for many of us meetings can be
frustrating challenging and even a waste
of time join us for our two episode
series to help us make meetings more
meaningful let's get started with
episode
one imagine this somebody comes up to
you and thanks you for running an
effective meeting it's possible believe
it we can have meetings that matter
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the
podcast today I am excited to speak with
Karen Reed and Joe Allen I've known
Karen and Joe for many years and look
forward to having yet another one of our
Lively and educational conversations
Karen is an Emmy award-winning
journalist and CEO of speaker Dynamics
Joe is a professor of indust industrial
and organizational psychology at the
University of Utah his research focuses
on workplace meetings organizational
Community engagement and occupational
safety and health together Joe and Karen
have written three helpful books on
meetings suddenly virtual making remote
meetings work suddenly hybrid managing
the modern meeting and running effective
meetings for dummies welcome Karen and
Joe thank you so much for having us Matt
longtime listener First Time guest good
to be here thanks let's go ahead and get
started Joe I'd like to start with you
you're a meeting scientist so I'd like
to have you set the stage for us why do
people hate meetings so much and can you
share some of the evidence that shows
meetings aren't as effective as they
could be about 51% of meetings are rated
as poor so people say meetings are poor
not just okay not average not above
average poor that means half the time we
go to a meeting and we're just unhappy
about it it right why is that one reason
is they're not very well run we don't do
them very well we tend to get into a rut
of habits around our meetings and those
habits aren't optimized for efficiency
or Effectiveness they're just kind of
what we kind of fell into with our team
or with our group or with whoever we're
meeting with and we just keep going that
way and it's become normative in our
society to complain about meetings and
so it becomes this perpetuating cycle of
I don't like meetings you don't like
meetings let's go grab a beer and talk
about how horrible and awful our
meetings are and we continue to do that
and so I think it's both the way they
are but also self-perpetuating because
we just believe that they're bad and
there's nothing we can do about it right
we do what we do because we've always
done it and part of that is having
ineffective meetings and then
complaining about them so Karen what are
some of the constraints and barriers
that lead to ineffective meetings
there's a lack of intentionality there's
no stated purpose there's no goal often
times you go into the meeting and there
isn't proactive facilitation to actually
get stuff done and that really puts you
back on your heels because you just
think wow that was a waste of time for
sure you also have a meeting bloat where
you have too many people in the meeting
who are there just because well we want
to make sure they're in the loop the
more people you have in the room the
more unwieldy that meaning becomes so
that is also a big challenge the third
thing I would point to is just
participation Equity can be really
really hard
to manage because often times it's the
loudest voices that are heard rather
than everyone's voice and if you're
trying to get something done in that
meaning you know make a decision based
upon everyone's opinion if you don't
hear everyone's opinion then you're not
going to be optimizing the ultimate
decision yeah several things there that
perpetuate ineffective meetings I know
that when I go in and do the Consulting
work I'll do sometimes the very first
thing I do is a meeting audit and see
how many people are coming to meetings
the number of people who attend meetings
is a defin sign of some of the
dysfunction in communication in general
because people are coming to the
meetings because there are no other
channels to get the information they
need SO meetings are often used as a
Band-Aid for that many things you
mentioned are really important I want to
come back to this notion of equity
because that's really critical
especially when we talk about hybrid
meetings let's dive into this whole
concept of participation equity which is
really essential to having a successful
meeting I want to give you some specific
strategies that you can try the first
one is validating all forms of
participation so there can be the one
where you traditionally raise your hand
and speak up but also chat is something
that you really want to leverage in a
virtual or hybrid meeting uh because it
is a lower barrier to entry if you put a
question out there and you give people
the opportunity to respond in chat or
out loud you can have people respond in
chat in a safer space where they can
give a little bit more forethought to
what they're saying and then you can say
oh that was a really interesting point
Jill can you expand upon that and at
that point maybe they're willing to come
off mute and talk more about what they
had initially introduced so I find that
validating both chat as well as spoken
participation is really really important
I would also lean into ensuring that
everybody has an opportunity to weigh in
by making folks aware of who is in the
room so having an opportunity for Q&A
could begin with the remote speaking
first as opposed to turning to the
person who is sharing the air with you
to your left and saying hey Karen why
don't you tell me your opinion instead
you turn to the screen and say I would
love to hear what you have to say on
this Barbara because I know you have a
lot of experience and then suddenly they
have the floor everybody is aware of who
all is in the room this notion of equity
is critical in meetings and elsewhere
but this notion of giving everybody the
opportunity to speak it's obviously more
challenging when people are virtual and
hybrid but I really appreciate that and
what I heard implicit in what you said
is you're actively listening and you're
demonstrating that listening and seeking
out that information and that's the role
of a good facilitator quite frankly I
think facilitation is one of the most
challenging of the communication skills
because you're managing time you're
managing participation you're managing
an agenda and you're managing your own
contribution so thank you for that
specific advice Joe I'd love to get a
little deeper into the notion of meeting
structures and what works especially
around aend gend I know you have an
opinion on agendas and I'd love for you
to share advice on if your meeting does
have an agenda where do you put the
easier topics versus the more difficult
or challenging topics and the ones that
are sort of in the middle there how do
you structure a meeting and how do you
use an agenda to help what can my team
handle and when can they handle it and
how can they handle it that sort of
thing and there's actually some good
research in group communication and in
groups and teams in general about in
what order should you ask a group to do
a easy or moderately difficult or a
difficult task right and this is both
when it comes to communication but also
into other tasks that a group might do
collaboratively and the research would
suggest that if you have three tasks one
being easy one being moderately
difficult and one being hard you would
start with the moderately difficult one
if the team is primed and ready to go
and so that's really the issue and when
I say primed I mean if you've done the
preting communication helping set the
stage for a very comfortable
psychologically safe environment they
know the purpose of the meeting the
overarching purpose of the meeting so
that way their brains are primed for
communication if you've done the right
scaffolding aspects of meetings then
they're primed and ready to go you
should jump in with the moderately
difficult item then go to the hard one
but you've got them ready to go if your
team is not primed or this is a new
group that you're meeting with for the
first time you need to decide whether or
not you feel like they can do that and I
actually would recommend for a new group
or for a group that you're not as primed
to get going I'd actually do a ramping
approach where you'd start with the
easier thing say let's start with this
easier thing let's kind of get to know
each other in this easier issue or
problem or thing that we want to talk
about and then move them forward onto
that so that way the priming also is
accomplishing something as well because
you're again you're with a group that's
not geared up and ready to go maybe you
don't know them as well that sort of
thing this makes so much sense to me
that we should be strategic in how we
think about the ordering and if you've
got a group that feels comfortable and
safe with each other they know the task
and the purpose at hand then you can
dive into a moderately challenging issue
first first to get things moving and
then consider perhaps doing the most
difficult next but you're really using
it to manage time so you're being
strategic in how you do that and then
similarly if your group is not one that
has been primed is not used to working
with each other then that easier task
might be a way to get started and to
facilitate that getting used to each
other so thank you for that advice so
Joe you and Karen were among the first
people to write about and publicly
discuss best practices for virtual and
hybrid meetings
what are one or two of the things we
should all keep in mind when we aren't
all meeting in the same physical space
two things seem to be kind of bubbling
to the top as being the most essential
things to make sure that these meetings
can be done effectively and that's being
seen and heard and so that's why when we
first started doing this we're talking
about you have camera on because you
need to be seen and then we have talk
about you need to be heard if your audio
is not working there is no meeting it
doesn't work at all and as we started to
think about that that's when we started
talking about equity and making sure
that everybody felt like they could
engage both through the technology as
well as interpersonally right and it's a
feeling as well as the actual behavior
of engaging and participating and so
when all those things started to be
considered we started to see this
commonality across these even as we
think about the more complex nature of a
hybrid meeting and actually playing upon
that Joe I mean it's that whole idea of
proximity bias yeah that you really have
to push up against all the time because
those who are in the room sharing the
same air think about the meeting just
being them those who are on the screen
virtually they think about the meeting
just being them and that's a problem
because when it comes to equity you know
you've got two meetings happening in the
same meeting and you got to join them y
so it puts the burden on the leader to
recognize that and make sure that they
manage that participation but it also is
a matter of Skilling up your people who
are attendees to understand who all is
there and who all is adding value and
even doing things like creating in room
allies where okay Bob you be the in room
Ally for Joe because Joe is attending
virtually today and then that means that
Bob is gonna make an effort to bring Joe
into the conversation whenever he knows
that he has a unique perspective to
share I like that idea of an in room
Ally as a way of really thinking about
equity in terms of speaking time and
contribution I like to advise people
that if you have a hybrid meeting
consider consider starting with the
people who are fewer in number so if
there five of us in the room and three
of us on Zoom I might start with an
agenda item that invites the people
remote first so we remember that they're
there similarly if I had more people
remote and fewer in the room start there
so this notion of making sure everybody
has airtime and is remembered and seen
very very important because we can have
negative consequences if we don't
encourage people to contribute so Karen
you spent a lot of time helping people
myself included with their onair
presence their video presence what tips
and tricks do you provide people so they
can shine when literally under the
spotlight one of the things that I find
to be the most vexing is eye contact but
it is so critical in terms of creating
that connection with your audience
unfortunately we are dealing with
imprecise eye contact where in order to
look like we're making eye contact with
our conversation part partner we are
looking at the camera and not at the
face of the person who we're conversing
with that is so challenging to get past
because we want to make eye contact but
when we look at the screen and not at
the camera it looks like you are doing
the exact opposite that you're looking
down you're looking somewhere else
entirely so what I tell people to do in
order to have your conversation partner
feel like you are being attentive to
them and connecting with them you need
to look primarily at the camera lens and
I say primarily because if you stare at
the camera lens and never break gaze
it'll freak people out it's like staring
at them in person like having a staring
contest you know exactly but in person
like we get the social cue that oh look
they're appearing to be uncomfortable I
should look away the camera doesn't give
you that cue so you really have to think
about not necessarily pouring your eye
contact through the camera lens but
rather pouring your energy through the
camera lens because the camera is the
conduct it to your conversation partner
or the portal to your people so that's
where you want to grow your energy and
play with it the way you would with a
person face to face we look away all the
time when we're talking to people face
to face do that when you're on camera as
well so that is one of the major things
from a performance standpoint and then
just to also remember this is a
conversation this is a pretty intimate
conversation that you're having when
you're on camera it's not like you're
standing up in front of the room or up
on stage and presenting you are are as
close to your conversation partner as
your eyes to your camera and their
screen to their eyes so stay in that
conversation space and interact with it
the way you would if you were actually
in the same physical room I think those
are wonderful bits of advice that it's a
conversation I like the portal to your
people I think that's a great way to
think of it it's a portal it's a
connection device I actually based on
some conversations you and I had I have
taken to taking a picture of my family
who on most days I like and love I tape
it right behind my camera so I'm
actually not talking to the camera I'm
actually talking to a picture of people
that I care about and that helps me look
at the camera rather than darting my
eyes around or looking at the screen I
know also Karen you talk a bit about
making sure you're well lit so people
can see you make sure you fill the
screen some people sit so far away they
look like a distant constellation in the
sky any other tips and tricks for how we
frame ourselves
I talk about the three-finger test for
example so it's hard to talk about if
you're not seeing it but keep this in
mind take three fingers like connect
your thumb and your pinky and stack it
on top of your head and that's how much
space you should have between the top of
your head and the top of the frame that
way you are taking up the majority of
the space and you're also giving them a
canvas to read your nonverbals that is
similar to the one that they'd be
reading face to face so that is a big
part of it also make sure your camera is
at eye level where you can draw a
parallel line from your eyeballs to your
camera and that is parallel with the
floor and then make sure that you are
sitting squarely in the space if you're
sitting slightly off kilter it just
feels uncomfortable uh for people to
take in your communication and then you
mentioned the importance of lighting
that is critical people want to be able
to read your facial expressions as
easily as possible we convey so much
through our facial expressions if you're
sitting in Shadow it'll be more
difficult for people to read the intense
to your message and then just make sure
that you have really good audio because
people are less tolerant of poor audio
than they are of poor video so if
there's a place to invest invest in your
audio so many Rich tips there Karen I
love the three finger test you know if
anybody has ever been a Boy Scout or a
girl scout you take those three fingers
put it on top of your head what it
really means is it's showing that you're
filling the screen with your body you
know so many of us look like we're in
the witness protection program sitting
in the dark I love your idea of having
good light and making sure that we're
seen and that we gesture and and behave
normally so thank you for those tips in
a similar vein Joe I'd like to get some
very specific tips from you based on the
work that you do let's start with what
advice do you have for managing someone
who is disruptive or just generally not
engaged or helpful in a meeting how can
we manage that
situation there's actually a whole host
of counterproductive meean behaviors
that I've studied over recent years
including things that happen in the
meeting you know monologuing
interrupting going off topic those sorts
of things and it happens a lot in a lot
of our meetings every meeting has one or
more of these kinds of behaviors that
emerges just naturally through the
conversation and that's not because
people are trying to derail the meeting
or to be difficult for the most part
some are but for the most part most
people are not that's just what happens
and so then you're in a meeting and you
may not want to call them out or to make
them feel bad but sometimes times you
have to you know interrupt and you have
to you know make an adjustment so that
way you can get back on track so the
general advice some of the earliest work
that I did actually with uh Nala Leeman
Willen brck a professor out of Hamburg
University looked at what we call
procedural communication and so it's a
very practical tip for all of those
circumstances where okay a person's
monologuing or a person has gone really
far off topic or they've interrupted
someone procedural communication is
really engaging in a proactive
communication strategy by saying hey
that's a great thought but I really want
more input on this or you just
interrupted Karen Karen can you finish
your thought and then and then it'll be
your turn to share your thought or just
doing those things and if you do them
politely as long as you're polite about
it generally speaking people are not
offended by it especially if that
politeness is really geared towards not
shutting them down completely but giving
them the opportunity to share their
thoughts in the appropriate way so the
moner who goes off on their favorite
topic you say thank you for bringing
that up that's a good thing to talk
about today today we're talking about
this do you have any thoughts
specifically about this and so it's not
about them not having airtime for their
thoughts it's having air time on the
right thing and so the tip is really
just being willing to be proactive and
correcting and redirecting and calling
people by name and that sort of thing to
keep the meeting aimed towards goals
aimed towards the agenda or to the
purpose for which you were there and
helping people understand that and if
you do that regularly
over a series of several meetings with
the same group or in your meetings in
general you'll both be teaching people
how to do that and how to communicate
effectively in their meeting and your
meetings will naturally get better with
that same group and when I do that I
actually have a reputation for running
an effective meeting that allows people
to communicate because I do that and so
when I go into new meetings people know
because they've heard that Joe runs a
meeting this way I'd like this notion of
really relying on procedural community
communication and you took care of the
second question I was going to ask which
is the person who just goes on tangents
Etc so what I'm hearing you say is that
you bring people back to the purpose of
the meeting you acknowledge what they've
said and then you bring it back and
that's often in line with what I coach
people to do which is to paraphrase say
I heard you I heard that you're talking
about this but now let's link or connect
back to either the purpose or to
something somebody else has said and it
is through that act of relying on the
procedural communication that you keep
things focused and that sets a role
model and example for everybody in the
room and one thing I would add to that
is if you have an effective
psychologically safe environment it
shouldn't all be upon the leader or the
meeting organizer to do those sorts of
things it is completely appropriate and
good if your team is collaborative
enough and feels safe enough to be able
to do that with each other right so you
may be running the meeting you may have
looked away to see where things are on
the agenda and someone else engages in
procedur communication to bring things
back to the agenda
that's wonderful and if you can get to
that point then you're really doing well
and hopefully you've got the environment
that allows that to happen for you
excellent yes it is everybody's
responsibility to make effective
meetings effective I have a question for
both of you Karen we'll start with you
what is the one biggest tip you would
provide to people to make meetings more
effective right size your meeting that
means having the right people in the
room with a realistic agenda that will
actually allow you to accomplish the
goal I think a lot of times people will
try to fit 10 PB of content into a 5B
bag and they think by perhaps speeding
up the pace at which they're talking
will allow them to do that but it
doesn't and then you end up just with a
lesser experience overall excellent so
it's all about Focus it's having the
right people focusing on the right
message and the right task thank you Joe
same question to you what is the one
biggest tip you would like to share that
can help meetings be more effective
running effective meetings is common
sense that's not commonly practiced and
the biggest tip I can give is to not be
afraid of taking a little more time to
make your meetings effective because it
will take a little more time but the
reason I say don't be afraid of it is
because one good meeting keeps you from
having a repeat of that same meeting and
we know that one bad meeting causes
three more meetings right so we know
that if you take a little more time and
practice those common sense practi I es
that we all know we should be doing with
our meetings you'll have fewer of them
if a concern for you is that you have
too many meetings this is the way to
solve that you'll have fewer meetings
with your team or need fewer meetings
with your team therefore you'll have to
adjust your calendar with them but by
doing good meetings if you do good
meetings you can have fewer meetings if
you don't do anything the natural flow
of communication natural rise of people
within organizations you're going to end
up with a busier
calendar so investment upfront in time
time can save you a lot of time on the
back end thank you absolutely uh before
we end I'd like to ask both of you
questions that I ask everybody the first
question will be honed and tuned just
for both of you and then we'll ask two
that I ask everybody so Karen I'm
goingon to ask you this one when you and
Joe meet and I know you met a lot
because you've written three books
together what is the one thing you
always did to make sure that your
meetings would be effective okay that's
so funny I feel like I'm being exposed
as a fraad because honestly meeting with
Joe was like meeting with just such a
good friend and so we'd always begin by
just catching up with what was going on
in each other's lives before we got to
any of the official work stuff that I
think you know perhaps that is a good
lesson to be learned for everyone that
you know inject Humanity into your
meetings and you'll have a more pleasant
experience and probably get more done as
well excellent and both of you are so
easy to talk to I can see how that would
be fun and useful to get you started Joe
I'm curious who is a communicator that
you admire and why Steven rerberg who
wrote the surprising science of meetings
considered the father of the modern
meeting science the one thing that he
does is that he tends to do what he says
that he does that's what's really
fascinating about his mentoring of me
and what he does um is that he's very
clear in his communication and does a
really great job excellent thank you
final question Karen for you what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe I'm
going to point to the ABCs of
communication so the first is
authenticity I believe that the best
communicators are steeped in
authenticity because that will help you
resonate best with your audience the B
would be brevity be brief be brilliant
be gone no one will be sad if you go
short everyone will be annoyed if you go
long and then the the C is Clarity
simplify your message because people
will not buy into what you're saying
unless they can understand it I love the
ABCs I love the Simplicity and
directness of it and I've loved the
Simplicity and directness of the advice
and guidance that you've given us today
Karen and Joe thank you so much for your
time your insights into how to make
meetings more effective be they in
person virtual or hybrid are excellent
and I encourage everybody to take time
to make meetings matter and make them
more effective thank you both thanks mat
thanks for having us thank you thank you
for joining us for another episode of
think fast talk smart the podcast from
Stanford GSB to learn more about making
meetings meaningful be sure to listen in
to our second episode of our twart
series you can also learn more about
effective meetings by listening to
episode number 42 with Sarah singer and
episode 14 with Bob Sutton this episode
was produced by Jenny Luna Ryan Campos
and me Matt Abrahams our music is from
Floyd Wonder please find us on YouTube
or wherever you get your podcasts be
sure to subscribe and rate US also
follow us on LinkedIn and Instagram and
check out fers smarter. for deep dive
videos English language learning content
and our
newsletter